[Music]
I feel like I lied to myself and I
didn't really believe I had a choice
that this was just the way I was going
to be way it was yeah like this I made
some mistakes that I suffered abused
alcohol like this is always going to
follow me forever and I've lived in the
extremes that was the biggest thing that
helped me of like you realize this is a
journey and it's not going to take
you're not going to be to hit this in
this one moment of
extreme reaction whatever of like it's
okay like it takes time this is 90 days
going on 9,000 or whatever the rest of
my life is cuz these steps like truly
changed my life the gift you've given
men who aren't bad guys but who grew up
believing that they really were somehow
broken they were unlovable they had done
a thing that they couldn't come back
from you've given them a picture of what
it can look like and I need you to
know that is Legacy changing stuff
that's how people change their family
tree